It was sort of. I was sort of.
Working on a minimalist thinking like that whole minimalist thinking i would run into that sort of quick.
Grab and mcluhan's. Thing and i was very very media. Aware because i was looked at to me was a whole study.
Not public art and. A quick grab and so that people make it simple as possible. Symbols and.
Simplify symbols of it becomes easier so. If you want to get through to the mainstream.
The real the people that are really out of it and somehow also twix them. I mean that was my idea.
So honestly by just creating subliminal images. So i was sort of working on a minimalist revelent.
And so i just had a simple quote also the whole movement. You know moving with a back with a pack of just one costume.
Which is easy. And then. I had banners and i had. Pints and things like that but i want to move into an area and.
Go to an action. Just a whole theater to work out the health of the kid.
And have to move in quickly and then quickly get into it. Water is this.
You know when things are happening really fast around you just just being in it.
And like there's sort of that instant sort of. Getting to sort of that sort of.
You know getting into a fine box and getting into superman costumes. That's sort of an area like.
Here you know you well yeah i like that here piers that's a theatrical thing.
But that was another constructs all sort of fantasy in my head you know. Like that sort of like these costumes like.
You turn into this. And i talk to mention it just it just appears.
Nobody knows who it is they up here what i see is this just this image.
So you play it play it up to them and the costume. Then. Be started to work the cost him in a sort of fine.
Writing and drawing so that that it's there. You know when it's picked up. On camera it's really clear and.
Turn from piper mash i didn't work too good with the skull thing to a gas mask concert's gas mask and is easily.
Cranked up easy to get. And that sort of says it lasts and.
And also putting a hood in connection with the with the with a air and breathing and pollution. So that symbols.
Sort of work that idea. And i keep working on a sort of. I still do it i'll keep working the ideas.
And the the costume on the back had. And the right so in the right when i was working thinking the pace. Actions.
Mark actions were around peace and the environment at one cost him a good interface. And has. And so.
I worked on that and.
And the dulles saw him that i had the dollar sign we had sort of red on the edges and gold which was an x..
I was a dollar x. And i used that name on mon i use that as. You know i like the. The x. In this.
You know like the takes a q so the execution of the dollar was there was the weapon. And.
But i also use it to play with it you know sort of use there's a guy. I use. I just play with the in the mind.
Sequence of just so he sees props and. In dance wise. There's multiple forms. And then the. Then the towards.
Then the whole
and even now if developed it even further so you've got it's totally environmentally plugged in there doesn't even talk
about in the right so in the right. Just says now. You know. Ecological destruction and. On it and.
And then i got to know have panels that go on to what they're going to interface panels i have just war.
Right so this is the image of we're all sort of say in the right so in the right to say well this is just war.
And you know missiles and. Barrels and drums. Build up a whole. Traveling kit and. A vehicle so it grew into a whole.
Traveling at fit. Show with banners and. You know. So that whole process.
Grew and it came to a crescendo when i went overseas with him just to take nevada and rocky flats and you know.
Woodstock and all that washington. And then i came back.
Recently and i come back recently and and you know so now it's really not easier. And.
This is getting down to what why i'm here now. Is actually we need to really get down to rest the right. You know.
The planet is indeed should we now have bad of these around the place. Sort of freaked the daylights.
You know like with all the information freaks that they live up to we badly need to get people.
Wiser had i can restructure their lives to heal the planet. And we need jobs the economy has to be around. Healing.
Healing the planet it's very clear.
Sort of we've gone through all the social experiments we've done now things that work we know what's got to be done.
It's not as if we don't know what's going to be done. We know what's not to be done. You know not to pollute the.
You know the nests that we. We live from. And we've got to. And we.
We've got to stop fighting one another incorporating in you on this to to might this. World habitable for everybody is.
That is what that's what the great one of the. Growing movement in general is these the. Is that movement. It's.
It's growing more i mean. I'm involved with the earth.
Repair at the moment you know was being involved with us repair found i was because i'm frank scuff from the united
nations day because i'm also interested in changing the symbols of the united nations for. Because united nations.
Is needs. Drastic. Reforming. And if it needs to recognize that we have n.g.o.s. And we could have an ngo.
N.g.o.s not not. Nation states running the show body. N.g.o.s as. As a form of. Of decision making.
Non-government organizations that help be people's.
Bicycles and got more people moving away from governments of making decisions.
As the power brokers but actually things come in with forums like. People. You go play.
You know groups like greenpeace and community ida broad and friends of the earth.
And a whole melody and that's growing more and more it is a people's movement. And so that's social groups.
Coming out from the grassroots and from different groups.
From different places around with people in pal them selves that the people are excited that power.
These these decisions. Coming out. Feed themselves through government sure you have the government.
Things but the ngos. Have to be. Listened to and has to be a major forum. I mean you don't go.
And it's growing more so i want to see you not it. You know. You know other nations really.
And at the beginning to move there that do have certain n.g.o.s in the united nations.
And the last call for us the first big first summit i was n.-g. O. Organize. So it was a big big part for.
Non-government organizations now you know that's a spiritual base is really important because that's why it's there.
We get it we talk. We involve with the materialistic world right. Well the material wealth.
Through meditation in my eye my experience from meditation. Sort of.
It made me aware that we live in a world of illusions. I mean i have been involved auditions. So that. That horse.
That spiritual connection.
He sort of grew actually being here in you know from my experiences i mean the whole experience has been experienced
period but my. You know i actually did these things. Totally out of from.
You know like what happened inside of me you know i think certain brought me out i mean.
I just got experience i mean i didn't know what i was entering into it's just these things came to me.
It's almost like. I was like a messenger that was sort of.
I was just part of the process and sort of linking up with other people in this process.
And this is a whole lot of stuff written up about in spirit sort of looked at it.
I mean it's the shambhala warrior type raisen that a warrior. Run by warriors and things like that. Yeah.
Well they're all sort of like. We need people want to talk about people coming on the earth and.
Rescuing the situation from the dark ages you know that's sort of destroying the planet.
And it's will be in full been written before. I saw talent. In things and. And you cannot sort of.
You know when you look at it and it's there.
And so that that became you know that's sort of our sort of join that bandwagon that's and. Sort of creating.
Being part of that that that. Movement. In my life style. But the spirituality is from observation. Around you is that.
You know you become aware that you're connected on one thing. And then you also that.
That you're also just this is this whole. Like you're actually right there in the here and now and.
You're observing and you develop this consists of observation but it's delusion.
Because if you see and hear things but it's not really. It's not tangible would still allusion ery it's elusive.
And so where that is all that. Ask that connection that you become to connect that you connect it. And then the us.
Is a living entity in itself you know that so living entities and.
I was after in that spirituality i learnt that all matter is spirit. Sit up at a point there is actually a living.
So everything. All matter is. And when we get down to recycling and. All of the rest of it the rest of the planet.
Will become that awareness that. That everything that's my and everything is produced.
I mean it's far fetched thinking you might be into the some people
but to me it's not far fetched that everything is recyclable everything. Has a place in the universe.
In this whole thing is just knowing. Just becoming a way that it says.
This matter is a very small matter is the spirit. And it's. It's a living entity and.
You know when you're in that mirror types of so you become aware that. For the few water any area.
You know you can have your heart when you're shitting and pissing
and all the rest of you just realize that you're just like another animal and.
You're an animal just like and but you got to this other thing here the global brine thing you know. Connects you up.
Can't put your finger on it but there is that connection. I mean i travel from here to america.
And a see the same paypal. Doing the same things the same connection i can see sign people.
Connect up in a striker doing exactly the same even look alike.
And i don't know why but i don't know how but you can see.
Act type images talk about act talk without any questions just doing things.
Exactly the same sly the global brain you know it's just that connection.
No answers no no i mean it's just there if you observe it.
You can see these can you know people talk about god and all the rest of knocking on the stand that.
And i could say oh it's all relevant. So if you don't not you just a guy sort of.
Squash everybody and so this is the why in the army why are you saying you know it to me are such.
You know develop your own. Process. And then keep keep keep keep an eye open mind.
And i sort of run into the guy a principle that. The living earth and and.
I feel that we can he or we can heal the world.
I mean is the healing we just got to be aware of what's destroying and really stop the.
And find solutions i'm just keeping my fingers crossed. But if we do. If it does go. Place.
I mean it's you and guys for you personally you don't it doesn't end life in general because all my free spirit.
Will be the world will go on like the universe will go on because its plants have come and gone
and so forth so we can have that sort of. Get away from us but at the moment i live on the earth.
And i'm going to try my best to be. Evolved person in this time. Yeah it's a great useful tool and it wasn't. Yeah.
Well the mind. I'm on drugs. Of its time. Was very real i mean that's true i mean that the mind drugs.
I experienced it before because i was. First of all so was i for seizing on hundred sixty sixty nine.
And i was slavin the whole city. Has it as a house. You know. It's called and. So become aware things in melbourne and.
The scene
and cause that sort of changed me i moved away from all my tribal connections with the family so i moved away from
those sort of roots and start seeing sort of these. You know if liking to seeing things you seen the illusion.
Talking about. Its illusionary human start seeing different things and it sort of.
Made you aware of certain senses and hearten the senses and so forth. But it also because i was sort of.
It was very special i really realized that community.
That cultures in the past was this part of a spiritual connection.
That i didn't go and just drop pills in the mouth all the time and we sort of abuse that.
That's where we've lost it in our society it's a consumerist society. And people want to have.
They hit all the time it was not made for that was made for special rituals and certain people used to not.
What people went through to get there. To be that and to use it for those sort of special events sort of become aware.
But in this sort of world we sort of moved away from that sort of. You know that's how it is i mean i can't say.
It's good
or bad i say that the death experience is good provided people know how to put the brakes on it because it was it's
becomes destructive just. So it has been a useful tool and and. And still. Well and i don't do it so he's got.
I wouldn't say little you know like doggy pains on sort of i went through a sort of. Means he can't by doing.
Be tripping on acid while on stage. And i'm going to put this on here. But i used to do that i used to. I used to.
I went through a stage of of. Tripping on stage will perform like i did all the rehearsals without all of that.
And did all my stuff and trip and.
And then i do things that i do things like i'll be on stage
and also get an idea of getting something i'll go off stage.
And get this thing and i'll see something in the audience i'll bring it up on stage you know.
I did things that totally freed me up because it just became this whole thing i was just you know i things were
stretched out time was stretched out there was no fear.
You know i took away all that because i was part of the whole carnival and performance
when i was performing i was i was the center of attraction.
At the world weather center with the other people around me. But it was very often a very useful.
In terms of growth spiritual. Yeah well that's that's. Well it's a living. Kind of the living theater.
It's a nine straight. In itself is a main street and that's what. I've been perceived since aquarius first of all.
And putting it up was doing it up so that. It's a billboard for that to keep it like that and. So it's sort of.
Nineteen that. That's a good thing about more of the murals that i used to it sort of keeps.
That link as a as a theatrical. Help that. Part of it.
But they are the other thing is that the people that come here it's like. Theatre.
Like people perform there and i dress up in a certain way.
And it sort of shocked the different dialects out of different people they're white i bet. But it's there.
Because i want to say well. This is how i feel you know. And. And it's just it's sort of been left.
Somehow it's been a place where.
That's what i'm grateful that newman has been a place where people can bring along their different ideas which are
totally. Not mean you know line with the with the smooth running cogs of society.
And and creates is this tension of this thing solve problems to be solved at this is the world out there.
Coming to name them. Which is the theater a little small little theater. You know the globe theater.
That you walk into without any. Rehearsals you just come in there's people just bring their a particular being.
And perform it in different ways. Oh yeah. It just carries on. Yeah. Carries on. You know that it carries on and.
You know when you have. You just look around it's. The billboard. Billboards.
All kinds of things that are happening around the place. For one thing it's a billboard. And even is a billboard as.
As well as. Big for a controversial form of new ideas which is made itself into mainstream.
And next week we've got the. The eco conference where you've got tourism.
As a step is that a vanity and what i mean veneers and hopefully. I mean it's.
Whatever the decision is going to be my name in will still be. That because that's how it's perceived outside.
Any white people not aware of what it is that the artistic creative spiritual.
Shermans in the world and i what name goodness were the ones who have been here that's just. Yeah it's great.
If you shoot into it. If you tune into that and it's there. For others it's a total a dismal.
That i would want to really try and my people the way that it's.
It's really it's it's it's just one place in the world which is very important for the world the way it is so real jam
and got to be grateful that we had inquiries first of all. And we need to celebrate of ish.
Just to bring out all the what it.
You know what are you know what it did then and who has developed up to now and just the whole culture and what we.
Developing and acil of russian is what we're developing towards. Twenty one the twenty first.
While more and more hype for the fear that that. Named and becomes. Well.
In the mind straight i like to see turn into a mole and. And the traffic rate directed at just on the physical level.
Like we do get funding. To do things. Have alternative ideas that are dreamt up.
That really work well for here do happen even i was terribly expensive to do that
but we can do it because a lot of things that gets short circuited. Because because. It's too expensive. But thank you.
If people put their heart and soul into like governments like. You know.
Let's do it it's a good idea that all the drug issue in the mainstream will be totally changed. If this becomes.
You know i walked thorough fair with all carts of people cars and cultures. Which it will be.
Once it becomes a more it will be a lot more people want all concert cultures all the change in him is changing.
That whole thing that of him and just being there sort of. That just sort of was a. Take a lot.
And not be just another saying which was. Well.
We need to find probably solutions to helping people that are really on drugs. You know i'm creating.
You know i really screwed up. And hopefully put in. You know the whole drug issues put in perspective.
Into perspective. In specially that. You know marijuana for instance you know and just suppression of the information.
For what it is. And then. That education would put it above and put it on level doesn't go underground.
Because people are destroying themselves you know with fear and and and. And they being.
Being manipulated being being exploited by criminal elements. Not not not by korean. Elements.
By elements which owing to the grade the same grades that i portray.
People into quick money sort of the chopping down forests and too.
For for it's for wood chipping and so for a multi national level. And getting a quick.
Get as much out of the environmental polluting. So that they you know just. Just so they can make money.
Just the whole thing is just making money out of drugs. And it's the same sort of mentality of people just.
Exploiting and exploiting people by giving him. Stuff that they shouldn't be given. And but i can't.
And the only way you can. Change that situation is. First of all to make a total.
Because police are involved as well as governments involved with the whole distribution of drugs.
Petrochemical companies might get the whole drug. Pop. Top popping drugs and it's not just about. About smoking.
And that it's always been with his drugs and. The only way that you can be mystified is education.
And is a better way of living in facades the positive of. You can do away with it i mean surprises you.
Certain people are going on to get off it and get on with. You know. Not destroying themselves i would so.
All rescue them before hand. By saying hey you know. We don't.
These are the alternative troi these things are you know you create people come to nimbin looking for.
Seeking a chinese you know it's or it's a refuge. It's a refuge to newmans a refuge for for people that have had it.
Had it really bad out there in the in the world. And it's a sort of a car and the place a toll in place.
So i mean these issues have to be addressed and.
As in those nice simplistic answers because we're dealing with a whole world. Global brian thinking about it.
So we just got a look at what other people have other people are dealing with the drug drug issues
and how it's changing and helping to change the law and these ideas. And hopefully name will come up with a unified of.
Idea to try to to change the situation here you know i've got my ideas of of. You know communities.
Where people can plant trees and. You know it seems for the environment and. Hang around music around them.
The whole thing of festival continuous festival. But i can. They doing things for the involved living on the us.
And they're doing things and they sort of.
Get involved with that sort of integrate themselves with with a culture that's one thing. I mean. This and just.
Infinite ideas of that sort of creative living. Creative living. And healing. L. Cells because the whole thing.
Aquarius was about survival. You know was the whole key thing of the chris festivals was crawling. Crying out.
We are destroying ourselves you know wars destroying the in the. The pollution it's unlike you.
We were aware of the pollution in the cities and it is at the back. Straight through. So. So we're going to save.
You know like. We save the planet that's the key phrase of.
Save the earth of woodstock at the moment you know the woodstock earth. For instance and.
But that's that's it we need to become healers on the earth. And so we've got a lot of knowledge.
Developed and got to keep developing because we haven't got through a lot of strength and individual.
Energy and be bright and. And exercise you off your communication skills. Rise and i hope everybody.
Puts energy towards nick she is a queer sort of it's not just about a festival.
It's about celebrating a period in town and. I'm all stoning time. So the ideas come out of the community. You know.
All forms of the community i mean or government. People coming out and and.
Put on a forum or want a forum about governments. You know. To get together with. About alternative government and.
And so forth and have it as part of the celebration. Anyone just on of the banner of aquarius foundation.
Three five forty five plug for their creators foundation. But they're curious. Next sherry's.
And through the name been used likening touchwood name been used to get in touch in even using that that name and.
This is a good. Good a good connection with. Development of the thinking of members.
Is so few people really want to know how neighborhoods. He's been developing and is subscribed to in the news.
He's a post office box name and two on on things like they're. Three on two on your part of his name. So that's.